la liberté enfin va redevenir la règle
et l'interdiction constituera
l'exception une bascule qui sonne comme
une bouffée d'oxygène pour les français
le pays repose quasi exclusivement en
verre seule exception les départements
d'ile-de-france mayotte et la guyane qui
constitueront la zone orange le
déconfinement il sera un peu plus
prudents a prévenu le premier ministre
parmi les interdictions levée il sera de
nouveau possible d'aller dans les parcs
et jardins en zone orange tous les cafés
bars et restaurants vont rouvrir en zone
verte ainsi que les terrasses dans les
départements classées en orange
la limitation de déplacement à 100 km du
domicile ne sera quant à elle plus
d'actualité à partir du 2 juin
edouard philippe a toutefois tenu à
rappeler la nécessité de maintenir la
vigilance
mais cette liberté retrouvée implique
des contraintes qui sont en quelque
sorte des contreparties la limitation
des regroupements à 10 personnes dans
l'espace public est maintenu le principe
du recours au télétravail doit toujours
être privilégiés on le comprend bien le
respect des gestes barrières surtout
doit rester très rigoureux et le port du
masque est maintenant largement
recommandée par les autorités sanitaires
nous continuerons et j'en suis désolé
mais c'est mon devoir a limité les
formes de la vie sociale les plus
propices à la transmission du virus les
sports de contact les boîtes de nuit les
regroupements de très large public en
particulier le ministre le dira il faut
éviter les rassemblements de personnes
dans les lieux couverts et sans
organisation adaptée
le ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer a pour sa part fait le point
sur les réouvertures des collèges et des
lycées
l'ensemble des collèges vont désormais
ouvrir que ce soit en zone verte ou en
zone orange en zone verte cela signifie
donc que l'on n'ajoute la 4e et la
troisième après la 6e et la cinquième
qui ont déjà ouvert donc l'ensemble des
classes sont ouvertes en zone verte en
zone orange
nous allons accueillir en priorité les
élèves de 6e et de 5e et si les
conditions matérielles sont réunies les
élèves des autres niveaux pourront
ensuite être accueilli l'ensemble des
lycées vont ou
rires avec un protocole sanitaire qui
est le même que pour celui des collèges
en zone verte
cela signifie que les lycées généraux
technologiques et professionnels vont
rouvrir et accueillir progressivement
les élèves dans le secteur de la culture
musées et monuments rouvriront à partir
de mardi prochain avec port du masque
obligatoire en zone verte ce sera
également le cas pour les théâtres et
salles de spectacles tous les cinémas
suivront le 22 juin l'interdiction de la
pratique des sports collectifs et des
sports de contact est en revanche
maintenue jusqu'à nouvel ordre
enfin le premier ministre a apporté des
précisions sur la saison estivale les
hébergements touristiques les villages
vacances les campings pourront ouvrir à
partir du 2 juin dans tous les
départements à l'exception de ceux qui
font l'objet d'une vigilance
particulière dans ces départements la
les hébergements en question des
campings les auberges collectif ne
pourrons rouvrir que dans la troisième
phase de déconfinement c'est à dire
après le 22 juin les déplacements y
compris en europe seront je l'espère
autorisée
concernant les relations hors europe il
nous faudra nous harmonisé avec nos pays
voisins et prendre des décisions en
fonction de l'état et de l'évolution des
risques je les dis les enfants pourront
être inscrits en colonie de vacances ou
encore de plein air des perspectives
plutôt réjouissante
après plus de deux mois éprouvants pour
les français